cambridge you have to remember had all
kinds of factories when I was a kid
growing up we had lever brothers we
still have a little bit of neck oh but
you had all kinds of little shops and
probably one of the most notable one
they had a donut shop on Main Street and
you can always smell the donuts okay
they still have Paul's which is a corner
store and even though we grew up and
left people still come back to Pauls
just for sub primarily a meatball sub
because no one makes a better meatball
sub than Paul's variety down on School
Street I'm Cambridge was Cambridge was
just so wonderful so memorable all right
growing up if there was ever an
all-america City it would have them in
Cambridge because she would have had to
have been here to know that to
experience it and to appreciate it okay
so i went to rob at school which is
called the manor now it's on a corner of
windsor and javed street i lived in that
community all my life when you're a
young man a little kid it's a big school
you know all my friends went there when
we went to school you'd go in the
morning and come home at lunch and then
go back in the afternoon ah you know
everybody in the community that I lived
in went there I gotta tell you we lived
in more of a multicultural community you
know how they were born matata posters
who agreed dil defranco's who was great
there was Roseanne and Everton and you
know do a Portuguese still people from
Barbados the Harrises Stephen Harrison
his family Humphrey Harris so I'm and we
wandered between the two projects
Washington was in Newtown court down
there at the gardens down by st. Mary's
and
wanted to st. Mary's where we grew up
with you know Timmy boiling a lot of
Irish kids that went to the Catholic
school to Cape Verdean kids we were a
multicultural community it was a
community where the statement today is
it takes a village you know to raise a
family and we were that village